greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by manscaped listen there's a public
service announcement for your nutsack
April as testicular cancer awareness
month every hour someone in this country
is diagnosed with testicular [ __ ]
cancer nevermind the [ __ ] coronavirus
it's early detected is your best friend
it comes to protecting your nuggets all
right this month manscape and the
testicular cancer society want to remind
you to check your [ __ ] coin sack at
least once a month you're sitting at
home playing with it anyway like a
[ __ ] idiot watching TV
your Ma's will squeeze it here squeeze
it there what you need to do is download
the ball check it out today for tips I'm
protecting your [ __ ] nutsack alright
search for ball checker wherever you
download apps that's the start is now so
talk to you about manscape you gotta F
after you realize you don't have
testicular cancer it's time to sling
some dick okay so what are you gonna do
you can't sling Corona dick right now
and you're sitting there your face looks
like the Wolfman we're all aging by the
[ __ ] day so we think your dick looks
like it looks like a [ __ ] fossil so
before you even go on the ball check
your app before you try swinging dick go
on to manscape comm and get the
lawnmower 3.0 with the goodies get the
complete [ __ ] package why are you
wasting your time go to manscape calm
right now
pressing Joey and get 20% off and free
shipping and check your balls it might
save your [ __ ] life Lee take this
[ __ ] meal on a Thursday
like [ __ ] Malaysians David welcome to
church
dude wait going nowhere but we're gonna
be [ __ ] fine we're gonna get to this
[ __ ]
it's uncle Joey on a Thursday morning
trying to bring you some love some
laughter some giggles we got a few
things to talk about I'll get out of
your [ __ ] hat and then you go on with
your life whatever the [ __ ] you were
doing last May I got a call from a
friend of my by the way listen we're
gonna be working these back and forth
this zoom [ __ ]
it don't work for me I don't like people
little heads look at that man's [ __ ]
like that
I feel like if something pedophile
looking in on somebody and they're
looking back at me then you put me
face-to-face I'm like the Brady but I
don't like it for me a podcast has
always been something more personal if
you know have you been through with the
podcast since day one we switched
formats 18 times we went from just us to
introduce ourselves to phone calls and
interviewing guests to bring in a guest
back in studio and then we go a Capello
from time to time now we're gonna run it
with this [ __ ] zoom the other thing
about zoom is I zoomed once not every
[ __ ] idiots reaching out to meet the
zoom I don't want to do them with nobody
you understand you wanna zoom zoom on
your own [ __ ] time
I don't wanna zoom with nobody I want to
zoom with [ __ ] the guests I have and
that said I barely want to do that and
you know I love Dean Del Ray and I had
other guests now I gotta call people see
if they got [ __ ] zoom for a month I'd
rather [ __ ] choke myself but anyway
you know it is what it is
technology everything's changing I'm
still not up with zoom so it's gonna
take me a few weeks so we're gonna go
back and forth and sorry get adjusted to
the two heads sitting next to each other
I got a look at my face and Dean Del Ray
too [ __ ] old men like where they were
about to get shot I don't need that
aggravation in my life but it's funny
you know ten days ago I was on the phone
with Ari and we were just talking about
you know everything that's going on he
goes you know the good thing is gonna be
about this that people gonna forget
about the petty things of life you know
what really [ __ ] matters this bro
first of all if you don't think there's
gonna be a silver lining out of this
you're out of your [ __ ] bird if
you're sitting there with no money for
the rain
you think about what you got to do
there's nothing you could do nobody
knows nothing unless you got a [ __ ]
ball in front of you you don't know
nothing so but here's one thing I do
know about this that there's gonna be a
silver lining from this either you're
gonna change careers either something
bad is gonna happen for you you just
taking a lump right now trust amount on
you man I've been in these positions a
thousand times this is the most
dangerous one
you know this attacks people like me but
I'm still telling you we got a chance
you young guys got a chance you're not
doomed I don't want anybody to think
that do them that they're done you're
not over and then over till the fat lady
sings she ain't even get in the [ __ ]
car yet well [ __ ] America and so
before you doom yourself don't do him
yourself all right you're just going
through a [ __ ] rough patch this is
what this is called in life for you
young guys your job you're not graduate
hey I feel for you I'd rather you lived
and you get together with a bunch of
eight hundred idiots perhaps on and
throw them up in here what's that gonna
do fear arms post time
nothing move on I never [ __ ] walk
down an aisle Joey Diaz come get your
diploma didn't do dick for you at the
end of the day don't do dick for nobody
I feel for you I feel free and I know
your pain and for you guys who just
started a job I feel fear you know but
everything happens for a reason anyway
I'm talking on Ari and we're
bullshitting about how hopefully this
will make people go back to seeing
what's important in your life like what
well I give a [ __ ] if we grab some
chicks tit 1981
enough knock it off go get your [ __ ]
life together all right you call the
cops no shut the [ __ ] up so me and him
just had this weight conversation excuse
me Coronas all over the place you watch
on the news on TV you online I can't
even look at the [ __ ] things anymore
I just look at my messages because it's
just too much Corona and you just get
depressed I feel a lot better lately
because I the TV isn't even going on
until 6:00 now now we got it till 6:00
not even 5:00 like it's just getting
later and later cuz my wife don't want
to hear it either nobody wants to hear
it no more
Liz there's nothing we could do we have
to move on but I'm talking about Ari and
we're talking about pity [ __ ] last I
don't know what's going on guys
I really don't I'm trying to hold in
school a child I've even tried the
homeschool a child no and especially
when you're a [ __ ]
come on school a child when you're a
[ __ ] well welcome to my world I'm
learning everyday I'm learning little by
little you know she's teaching me things
I'm teaching her things yes they went
back there we ended up doing math we got
caught on percentages it's not all about
10% of my action my action I was here
you get 50 yet I talked about the small
50 I'm working it with Matt but I'm
trying to give her a different
perspective
I used ice yeah I use I give her an
amount of money to count it I tell it
count $23 let me know how much is there
I made a mistake I'm gonna see if she
tries to D the dollar from me don't say
this 23 she counts 24 does she take a
dollar I'm teaching her all this stuff
this is the way I learned it yeah it's
great to learn you know she's learning
division I'm working with her a lot on
math I'm good with numbers and thinking
real quick Wow so I'm busy guys this is
this has been a real life change in this
homeschooling if you're a parent my
heart goes out to you I know what you're
going through so I don't really know
what's going on in the world
I know Bert's got a thing on I know the
comedian's got together I've spoken to
her Eddie a few times I've spoken to Joe
maybe once I've spoken to Theo
I talked to Simone every day Dean every
day but I don't really know what's going
on like specials and [ __ ] like that so I
got a call from a friend of mine in
Texas who was an old comedy club friend
my old coke dealer I had one of the
comedy clubs he was the manager buddy
also supplied all the comics would go
good guy you know I still keep in touch
with him I don't do coke but let's don't
keep touching him
and he called me to ask me if I had seen
the little new Lewis week a special but
it was very funny and I'm like louis c.k
has a special so right away
night I want our Netflix and I didn't
see no louis c.k that I'm like what am I
[ __ ] thinking he got thrown off of
Netflix you know and then my life turned
into whatever and I forgot all about
Louis DK and then two days later I go on
Twitter and there's this big write-up by
Time magazine on New York Times it's
either one of those two that louis c.k
released a special i made this so i
click it and i'm reading
i want to see what the [ __ ] you know
because in my mind I'm thinking
something completely different right now
so I'm looking at this review and it's
racist and it's dark and he explains
what he did and ba-bop and I finished a
review and sure the guy who wrote the
review didn't like it and he was pissed
off that Louis released it you know kind
of sort of expect that this is what I
was getting but me I'm looking at from a
different perspective
you know I'm looking at it now from like
this happened in 2001 it got brought to
light after he blew up I don't know that
I heard about cover-ups and [ __ ] like
that listen guys not for nothing I heard
about something happening in Aspen in
2001 I whether was 2001 - tired
something happened Aspen with Louie I
didn't know what now have you had guys
ever lived the life of a comedian have
you lived the life on the [ __ ] rocker
have you lived the life of a perfectly a
person in the public eye
it's got his perks and it's got its
negatives okay one of the perks is for
some reason women lose their [ __ ]
mind
over certain things when when the movie
motley crue came out the crew whatever
on Netflix it opens up with him heat and
the girls [ __ ] that was a squirter at a
party and it was you know that was
Motley Crue they break came over the
[ __ ] you know right and Rudy Sarzo said
to mega what do you think of the movie
because I enjoyed it was entertaining he
goes it's just really hard to understand
all the me too
how come people aren't freaking out more
about me - because that was a different
time
that was the 80s it was a different
[ __ ] time you know I'm not saying it
was okay to rape women or what sleep
imposed and I don't know anything about
that but what went on the road was just
you know it was mayhem
I've sat here with you many a night one
night especially up at the top of that
corner here when I was still living up
the corner and we talked and I was
shaking
I'm telling you of all the [ __ ] crazy
encounters you have as a young comic on
the road and how crazy they really are
you know and you can look at it from two
ways you look at it from any way you
want I mean it it's just it's a weird
way of living you know and now we're
seeing it through the years with Harvey
and [ __ ] Cosby now people's eyes are
getting a little bit more woken - what
happens out here and you know so you get
mad at a guy like Cosby and Harvey but
there's another side to the story and
that's the sign of meeting a celebrity
or sleeping with a celebrity or getting
help from that celebrity okay and let me
tell you something I always knew for
some reason I got an early idea early on
that nobody could help you in this
business I got it figured out that the
people I liked all stood on that stage
long and that really nobody can help you
I mean it's it's the craziest thing that
you think that somebody could shine
light on you yes somebody could say
Diana Ross could walk into a room and
say whom I like the Jackson 5 but the
Jackson 5 still have to do their work Do
You Know Who I am and once you realize
that but for some reason a lot of women
come out here they're a little on the
hot side you know they know it
they've got a little garlic fart fully I
told them one was coming long time right
now that wait for this this will kill
Corona Corona scauses and every [ __ ]
body I think that's what Corona got
started this is a bad move on this will
kill everybody Warren oh so I don't want
it sprayed now yeah you need this garlic
in your lungs it's good for you it's on
Claud what are you [ __ ] little
[ __ ] heart valves that's why I eat it
to clean out my vows anyway getting back
what we're talking about no wonder with
you know this nobody slept with me but
I'm just saying that this is weird thing
that a hot woman comes to town and you
got to see it first of all you have to
see when new meat walks into an open mic
that's what it is it's new meat she goes
on stage she bombs and every comic all
of a sudden things she's great the girl
is a six and God forbid the girl go up
there and say she's single [ __ ] you
ever seen the Sharks how the fins come
out of the water yeah that's exactly
what happened when a girl shows up to an
open mic with a pretty dress and she's
like I've never done this before I need
help every Barracuda comes out until
they realize she's not gonna suck their
dick or she's gonna suck their dick all
they have a boyfriend it really changes
for them so that's what and you've seen
it oh yeah dude since once you see it
you go oh that's why everybody you could
be you're a guy you go up to have a
great set nobody wants to talk to you
all sudden some chubby girl comes in
with big tits and she's got no Brawn oh
my god all the comic scholars come on it
happens a little bit not not as much but
I've seen hot guys get a different
reaction from from people too it's not
it's not as it's not as crazy but nobody
wants to know our guy doesn't want to
[ __ ] the hot guys and girls three girls
aren't gonna circle a young comic to
[ __ ] give them advice like three guys
are certainly a young comic to give her
advice it's big difference
so when a girl comes into a comedy club
she's new [ __ ] meat you know and
that's that's a sad way to put it but
it's [ __ ] true so now this girl has
to struggle but before she could become
a comic she asked the struggle hallway -
what the [ __ ] is real and what the [ __ ]
is not real which is tough right off the
bat you got to decide what's real and
what's not [ __ ] real here so it's
tough enough for a female comic
I'm not saying a female comic is wrong
Pope nobody was right and nobody was
wrong so my take on this is that they're
all partying and Louie asked the girls
to their room he's the hottest comic up
there at the time or one of the hot
comics up there at the time I'm only
mean I don't mean looks I mean he's
[ __ ] destroy right they go back to
his rooms this will happen I thought I
was the green room but it could be
possible to deliver and he asked them
yeah you asked and they giggled and he
took his dick out he jerked off will he
come I don't know about stories that
some people say yes and some people said
no and if he if this if they said no he
wouldn't do it
that's right and then now other women
came out and said he jerked off in front
of them or that he was jerking off while
he was in the phone with both Sarah
Silverman said that he would ask her
occasionally she said sometimes she
would say yes I mean yeah it's a very
weird look but come 2016 15 years later
they finally get enough momentum and
knock the kid off the pedestal okay
whatever pedestal you want to call it
stand up his fame he loses money I hear
one of his daughters isn't talking to
him
Wow you know movie is gonna come out
yeah something else happened never mind
the monetary losses just what he lost in
character what he lost in shame here's a
guy that's a perfect candidate for you
to call up and when somebody calls and
says did you hear about Louis what he
hung himself here he was the perfect
candidate yeah he was the perfect
candidate you know I even hear in his in
his routine
talks about which I'm gonna watch the
special I hear he talks about you know
going to restaurants and people flipping
him off and [ __ ] what he did was not
tough now we have a moral dilemma here
what does it take for us to forgive
Louie in my world I have daughters it's
done with it's done with her I'm gonna
tell you why it's done with because he
went away like a man
he hid like a man I think he seeks some
type of therapy you know I heard
something from I don't know how true it
is you know I guess I always ask when I
speak to certain New York comics I ask a
minority I ask about you know just let's
see how the [ __ ] are they doing now let
me ask you your opinion on this you just
mentioned forgive him do you have to
forgive him could you just enjoy his
special and see he's a [ __ ] guy but I
enjoy a stand-up but do you have to
fully forgive them to be able to walk
that's a great question but you mean you
and the third [ __ ] wall I have no I
have no power to forgive him who the
[ __ ] mind
what the [ __ ] mind it didn't happen
so you're right what the [ __ ] am I to
forgive him or not forgive him I'm just
telling you I feel about it my world it
was 15 years ago he did not go up and
make negative tweets you know oj saying
man whatever killed joe exotic I don't
[ __ ] know you know he hasn't made
derogatory tweets he hasn't rubbed it in
anybody's face he's just a guy that's at
home felt he took his lumps which is
what a what an American person does is
we go home we take our lumps we figure
out what went wrong and we either shoot
ourselves or move forward so I have to
applaud Louis for moving forward again
he didn't bother anybody there was signs
up at clubs if you want your money back
you can have your money back
and then what did he do did he come to
the Tommy store and try to bother people
did he come to the main room at the
Denver comedy work no he went to
different little rooms little rooms
where it doesn't matter to those people
what happens in Hollywood you follow me
they know Hollywood is a [ __ ] up place
you know they don't give a [ __ ] when
Brad Pitt says the boat well that they
don't give a [ __ ] Hollywood does not
influence them at all he went to all
those rooms and did a bunch of those
rooms from what I heard and sold out
then he went up to Cameron up Canada and
they did whatever the chain is up there
and I had that guy got a bunch of grief
and he sold out all the shows and I
heard it was 40% women and they were up
on that feet and clapping - so what was
the purpose of this [ __ ] article that
time wrote and maybe was the New York
Times I know New York Times wrote one I
don't know if it was time or the post or
I don't believe none the [ __ ] post
says anyway I stopped on following those
[ __ ] lies a long time ago they just
[ __ ] lie you read the New York Post
they even make up their own bookmaking
lines you go to Vegas they give a seven
you go to the polls they give him five
what the [ __ ] that I just missed because
they make their own [ __ ] lines the
post I think they're [ __ ] cute so uh
you know I read this [ __ ] thing and
I'm like what is the point of this I
tell you what Louis did I liked him the
most out of this he didn't advertise it
he didn't hire a publicist he didn't
bother nobody to go on a show he
released it off his own web page yeah
and this is the smartest trick on
everything and it's not a trick it's
marketing what was his other CDs price
for five widely charged 2009 mine cents
more fees irrelevant because he knows
that for five anybody will buy it but
for $7.99 you really gotta like him yeah
and he didn't want nobody watching him
that didn't want to watch it he made it
comfortable to a Netflix he made it
comparable to a Hulu I don't know what
Hulu is I'm
on the Netflix but he if you remember he
was the one who started that five dog
started it so why didn't he go back to
five he went to seven ninety-nine
because he wanted to for you to really
think about if you really wanted to
watch this right you really have an
option to turn this off I'm not watching
it all move on with your [ __ ] life
and never to mention Louis CK's and like
the other side I think we mentioned at
the beginning how like something good
will come out of it like some like you
you'll either just get a new job or this
and that it kind of relates to his story
and I don't know he made a ton of money
so we might have savings yes he's a
great comic and when I was an open mic
that he was already banging out calmly
right and [ __ ] scripts but he
couldn't work an awful lot of the people
you know yeah he didn't work for three
years crazy and not even like with this
with Corona yeah you kind of can't work
but there's still jobs out there imagine
like imagine getting he stayed in
[ __ ] paid his dues he didn't go out
and squall the chicks [ __ ] on social
media he did nothing of that no I have
to tell you the truth he acted like a
gentleman and he acted like somebody
that deserves a second chance it's time
that [ __ ] you know I'm saying we got
people dying by the minute here we got
you know the world's coming to an end if
you listen to Eddie Bravo and q5 and
[ __ ] Cuse and Roman yeah there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on so for you to
[ __ ] take the time out of your busy
day to write an article about Louisa -
and and and at the old end of the day
this is what pisses me off the most you
ready
bye you writing that article you're
making the guy a millionaire yeah so
what you intended to do you know I love
it I listen I come from the day of Brian
Bosworth when he would go into a stadium
and there'd be people lined up hating on
Brian Bosworth
and a bunch of people with Master said I
hate Brian or whatever the [ __ ] they
were but when nobody knew was he owned
the company I loved it when you guys
when I was growing up and you guys
boycotted dice and you broke his albums
and you did all that stuff what happened
he got even bigger he played the garden
and you [ __ ] twelve little lonely
chicks were out there with you bald
heads you know he he hates abortion
you're selling more tickets because
you're making people stop to see what
the [ __ ] is going on it's the dumbest
thing I've ever seen in your life you
got something to say shut the [ __ ] up
and you hurt the guy financially but for
you to write an article in the New York
Times you know to put the guy down
because he released a special that's
gonna make him a million dollars you
just enabled him that's true but I was I
was gonna I was wondering about this
this is like the past week like even
yeah he hasn't made of money but that
must have it must hurt him to see that
when that stuff comes out like sure it
hurts him do it hurts um he's a human
being do you ever regret like I know you
love stand-up but you ever regret like
getting into like the public eye like
all that like people can wear whatever
they want say whatever they want it's
like at some point it must drag on yeah
it's I got into the public's eye in a
micro-level and I knew what I felt like
and I knew what my mind did to me at a
micro level because remember somebody
saying something about you and somebody
writing something about you is two
different things how your mind sees it
is two different things
somebody's saying some about you and
somebody writing it down and you reading
it really [ __ ] her your psyche why he
read tons and tons and tons of articles
about himself at one point he stopped
because he knew it wasn't getting any
better and he looked at the brighter
side of what was going on not to answer
your question about the public eye
when I got into stand-up comedy I could
truly look you in the eye and anybody
else in the eye and say I got into
comedy to drop out I wanted to drop out
not drop it I realized what this problem
was around three weeks ago when they
started because you're alone and you're
isolated I'll let you think I'll let you
write different things what I did the
Netflix special that bothered me the
bombing didn't bother me as much as the
[ __ ] location where I did it
you know Netflix didn't bother me they
were great Netflix had nothing to do
with this you want me to tell you what
bothered me and everything I had worked
for the drop out I was going against I
was dropping it when I became a standout
it was to drop out to drop out of
society to live like Tom Barringer's
character in major league one week
you're in Mexico sleeping with chicken
this with two chicks on the bed with you
and the next week you're in Montana you
may not be making a lot of money you're
making them mean of the season minimum
the player minimum but you're doing what
you love and I'm not in prison yeah that
was the whole point of this [ __ ] for me
to get into stand-up it wasn't to end up
in LA under the public eye shaking hands
with people that took a lot and they'll
get us on to our next subject which was
a very good question you know nobody
when I was growing up nobody really knew
what anxiety was everybody put a
different name on it or whatever
everybody put a different name on it I
used to get asthma as a kid as a kid I
had a really bad asthma I see it
yesterday when I was playing with mercy
she's got asthma
you tell because the Chiefs can't read
and then a mom asked to hit it with a
[ __ ] squirt of that [ __ ] so even
though yesterday she threw those [ __ ]
mine pound balls a hundred times she got
a little bit of it I don't let her
a mind to it so it goes away like my
mother did me but for years I had asthma
growing up and I would have to stop and
my mother would have to hug me and hit
me with a shot or something and [ __ ]
then I could breathe again over the
years my mom didn't cater to anymore and
eventually it went away but that reading
from that respiratory thing always
stayed with me and it always stayed deep
and my psyche so even when I played
basketball all those years there was
times I was playing basketball and I
would lose focus what I was doing and
it's like dr. police said when we had
her here that we have natural breathing
until worhty nee Jers and then we have a
traumatic experience and we go away from
it that happened to me and somewhere
along that line a thing was created and
inside of me that was called anxiety of
fear now since I was a kid and I was an
immigrant I always felt insecure but for
a long time after my father died that
fear fear is natural your father dies
now I'm scared that my mother's gonna
die who's gonna take care of me borrow
bah
so this is something that's ingrained in
you as a young man or whatever the [ __ ]
it is you know and then as I got older I
started smoking pot and doing drugs and
I self-medicated you know with the drugs
and that took care of a lot of it and
then when I became a full-blown junkie
on the cocaine and I realized that I
needed a bump you know for a long time I
just did a bump like anybody else you
got one let's do one but then it became
a point where I needed more how many
years in was that didn't six Wow six six
or seven will you get to the point where
you become like a mouse you'll pick
cocaine over sex food sleep you pick
cocaine or anything that's what an
addict is called you know and and I did
that for a long time
and you know I still got my little
things a [ __ ] like that and then I
started getting sleep apnea when I got
really big nobody knew what that was
nobody know what that was and I started
getting sleep apnea where you wake up in
the middle and like choking to death and
you have no [ __ ] idea you wake a bike
from a nightmare you know so all these
little things plus the fact that I do
stand-up now from day one of stand-up I
mean it took me [ __ ] 18 months to get
on stage so what is that tight you're
scared of something it's not like some
people go that you know a lot of people
say they went to see a band and they got
there early and there was a talent
contest that met their friends brought
him up I applaud those [ __ ]
yeah I had a friend Dan oregano god rest
his soul I took him to an open mic in
the city they were doing the talent
contest and he goes let's wait let me go
up on stage I was so [ __ ] proud of
them cuz it took me 18 months like a
little [ __ ] to make notes and what are
you gonna get up on stage soon you just
fear you just fear but once I broke that
fear I got on stage and here we are 29
years later but any great performer will
tell you or any-any anybody anybody the
chick that played the violin a rapper
that will tell you that they get jitters
before they go on stage yeah some people
puke remember the first time I saw
Gabriel's from puke I had heard about it
for years like every time he goes every
time he goes on stage he lets out a
[ __ ] Exorcist barf on the side wipes
his face takes a sip of beer and he goes
and destroys the [ __ ] place
we all have our [ __ ] shortcomings
that's what the great thing about being
a human being is him saying so I keep
going through this bubble over Bob I
meet my wife and I I didn't know
anything about anything she takes me to
the doctor we get the sleep apnea
corrected and then she takes me to my
main doctor and her and my main back
they were talking and they're talking
about [ __ ] anxiety and that he's got
it he gets it at certain times he
doesn't even know it and then I went
home and she broke it down for me as she
explained to me what anxiety was [ __ ]
all these years I've been getting this
feeling you know I remember before I
went together whatever I gonna get a
needle that's what I feel just all these
different things came into perspective
that I didn't know about and here I was
35 years old so the doctor at that point
prescribed me pills for my anxiety he
prescribed me high blood pressure
medication two pills once I take in the
morning when I take at night they also
gave me something for my thyroid they
took a blood test Joe Rogan was the one
that told me to check my thyroid I
checked my thyroid and they gave me
medication to speed it up you know
because I was putting on weight too fast
so he's just a bunch of things that that
happened and you know me doc I'm alright
at it [ __ ] you don't say I don't want to
take no [ __ ] pills you know I would
go to a blood pressure he's like I've
come in blood pressure is so high you
take my medication I'm like yeah sure
I'm gonna take you through thick I'm not
taking that gun but he sat me down when
Benny goes you gotta take your
medication when I give it thee you gotta
take all of it so I started taking the
blood pressure medication and then I
would get these feelings in time to time
I would go one of these [ __ ] feelings
and Terry would look at me and go you're
going to a panic attack and I would go a
little bit and she would go on the back
and come out with a little football
white football and give me a white
football and I'd eat the white football
I'd be fine and she goes at any time to
get these attacks eat eat this white
football you know so it's not like I get
the attacks in the daytime and nothing
like that you know I'm smoking reefer
I'm eating my edibles I started getting
anxiety at night now am i alive for
telling you this yes I am a liar but let
me explain something to you
my basic anxiety starts at 7:30 because
that's when I used to want coke why are
you a liar because I tell you that I get
anxiety every night at 7:30 that's not
completely the truth I only get anxiety
in your 4 out of the 7 nights but I
don't know what I'm gonna get anxiety
right and that's why before I go to the
comic store I always put one of those
footballs in my pants and nine out of
ten times I don't take it sometimes if
I'm going to the main room left to go in
the original room and I get anxiety I
pop them after I had the anxiety attack
with met Morgan Murphy oh that night
that was really really really bad down
there I decided to start bringing a pill
down with me if I took it before I left
the house I would get dizzy remember
when I was getting carsick going down a
hill okay so I figured out that I had to
take the pill when I got to the comedy
store if not I would [ __ ] throw it
away I wouldn't so sometimes when I walk
to the main room I go onto the green
room and I see all those people I closed
the door and I go onto the hallway by
myself and I go on my pocket and I pop a
football and that's what I've been doing
for [ __ ] it's okay
and I doom as I take them then I started
realizing on the road if I didn't have
an edible I could take one and fall
asleep on those nights when I football
for three hours yeah well those folk but
if I take one of those and the little
white blood pressure medication they
relax me
even sometimes an Aleve relaxes me at
night like I've tried to do two shows
and I'm wound up so this is what
happened okay this is exactly what
happened it wasn't when the doctor gave
me these footballs he said to me I could
give you something stronger but I can't
because of your sleep apnea
now without throwing anybody under the
bus in this town somebody has already
died from sleep apnea and taking xanax
years ago
it's nobody's business who was I just
know for a fact that's what he died
that's what he was doing so because of
that I will take anxiety medication for
anxiety but to sleep I will take edibles
I will drink the quickies I will eat 300
milligrams
oh I'll [ __ ] you know I'm saying we
don't put me to sleep no more right we
used to put me to sleep
not anymore because of my dog yeah so
I'm the top all that [ __ ] off when I go
on the road as you know and as you've
seen people give me liquid acid they
give me purpose of stuff they give me
vicodin they give me [ __ ] those pills
that a really bad fear I don't know what
they are codeine out to be honest with
you people
I keep the percocets do I eat percocet
Slee no I keep the the vicodins whatever
those pain pills are oxy oxy no no no no
somebody gave me an oxy and I gave that
away somebody right away I have a friend
who eat all that [ __ ] people give me
strange peel pills on the road I'll take
them and then I'll give them to him but
there's some pills out here right like I
was telling my wife Jesus Christ I'd go
for one of those [ __ ] when they shot
my knee before the Sopranos yeah the
next day at her time I could go for a
[ __ ] vicodin too bad I don't have one
and then two days later I wanted my
jacket pocket
that one was and then somebody at the
comedy store gave me three percocets
which if a pain a wondering the [ __ ]
during this quarantine that was at home
one night born I ate one I was like man
these things [ __ ] up so I never
anything again so that's it but I
usually eat my little footballs if I get
whatever but again then I got my boy one
of my boys in Jersey
he knows who it is he listens to the
podcast he hooks me up from time to time
with those bars okay zanuck the booze
annex bars okay so I wake up the other
morning after the louis c.k there's only
two days later
and some guy sends me a message hey man
[ __ ] this dude that's talking [ __ ] like
[ __ ] so I didn't know the dude was I
don't know what's going on so again I
wake up the next day I don't hear
nothing then yesterday I go online this
is big thing Joey Diaz is on xanax I
caught him I know this is interesting
finally somebody called me out I'm
saying I [ __ ] click but before we get
to that about six months ago I came home
and I was writing a bio for this year to
have on the road you know when you write
a bio for the road you know born ending
why they're saying them whatever so when
I'm IMDB page and I'm IMDB page it says
the Jim Norton
documentary Joey COGO this and I'm like
hmm
now I know I smell reefer my plate but I
don't remember doing the Jim Norton
documentary for all of me let me find
the Jim Norton documentary and see what
this is all about and it was like the
rise and fall of Jim Norton and I'm read
I'm watching this video and I'm
fast-forwarding to it and they finally
came to us it's him on the podcast okay
talking so they used our footage so they
had to put my name on it
Oh God so I'm watching this thing and
it's like the rise and fall of about
perverts and this and that and whoa whoa
what rise and fall of Jim Norton yeah he
[ __ ] his on the radio it's a great
show he's still selling out tickets and
he's still funny in the [ __ ] ever he
just shot the degenerate what rise and
fall and then if you look at on that
page it's who stole Patrice O'Neal's
money did you see that one no the dista
Brendan Schaub document yeah that one
don't another comedian that they
tortured and I go oh this is a new thing
I gotta wonder when I'm gonna get mine
you know saying even there's a joke I
got wonder but they torch them for shop
because nobody no shop he's been don't
call me for three years really expect
from the shop to be [ __ ] read
you dumb [ __ ] so yesterday I
get up and I click it and I'm watching
this guy and I'm waiting for some
intelligent feedback for him to say Joey
Diaz is a problem but bla he I'm fat I
look like I'm 80
when do I work out the dumb [ __ ] chick
is saying [ __ ] that who would do
jujitsu with me I mean it was just and I
just stopped it and then he's like this
is how you know a junkie he doesn't know
the name of what he's taking bah bah I'm
gonna tell you what cuz I don't take
xanax Lee what's the name of that jail
right there up on top so you can read to
the people at home read everything
that's on that label read my name not my
address but all right
social security number no I'll
alprazolam I'll preserve them that's why
I didn't know the [ __ ] name on it on
the jory I can barely read it keep
reading
yeah a pozzolan or something like that
uh tablets 0.25 milligrams okay what did
I say I'm the Joe Rogan podcast 0.25
okay and it's a generic for the xanax
tabs okay take one tablet three times a
day as needed okay ID okay
and that's prescribed by a doctor
package 101 what's the prescription
that's it okay so for you for the guy
whatever I'm not even gonna mention your
name cuz then I looked on your other
videos and you're making fun of Cheetos
and Pinot and you're making fun of
[ __ ] Chris D'Elia and you're making
fun of people who actually they're doing
something with their life you wrote a
[ __ ] video about cheeto Santino not
having any content and Chris D'Elia who
the [ __ ] are you the content you but now
is content that's garbage you mean while
you're sitting there were you little
half a [ __ ] whiskey and that [ __ ] who I
know has Corona no [ __ ] because she
can't be so [ __ ] stupid
and you point your fingers at comics who
actually try and who actually [ __ ] go
out there on the weekend
and watch you are doing something with
their [ __ ] lives that's what you're
doing in here
I got the [ __ ] proof for what the
[ __ ] you're talking about I'm addicted
to that I lied about what does it say in
the name is that's why I don't know
it's a presume an a generic new blend
for xanax
but even though what was it what were
the [ __ ] things 25.2 [ __ ] fives
only your little [ __ ] ass would get
high on one of these your little [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it was just it's just
people that this whole thing wraps up
and somebody gave them permission to
attack some [ __ ] guy listen you want
to call me a call Mia
call me out for my tolerance call me out
for the amount of [ __ ] nuts edibles I
do you calling me out for a thousand
things don't call me out for something
that don't exist because you wanna not
even profit just to make yourself look
[ __ ] smarter now I don't like to
carry this around with me this makes me
look like a [ __ ] idiot
I don't think I should carry these with
me so you see these what these are these
are a sunglass case it's always in my
bag okay and these are the glasses that
go in there if you watch the podcast I
know some of yous listen to it but if
you watch it these are the glasses to go
in there a prescription no they're
[ __ ] it whatever but in here in case I
have an emergency because this is how I
roll because you have no idea what it's
to have anxiety I have greens Annie boys
that a friend of mine gave me on the
road and if you want I can have him call
in to tell you what he gave me these
things so he gives me these Annie bars
and what I did was I put some in my
suncast case in case I get an anxiety
attack while I'm on the show and if I'm
driving I have them in my bag and you
know blah blah blah blah
the other thing of the purpose is I'm
not lying to nobody about my [ __ ]
shortcomings
I'm 57 why did no one because if they're
special to you you're gonna [ __ ] it up
with a lie and if they don't matter like
this jerk-off who the [ __ ] today that
you gotta lie to them cool and I watch
that's why I asked you the question
because I watched the first ten minutes
and I had to shut it off just cuz it was
it was bothering me like y'all all his
research was watching the Joe Rogan
podcast and then and the thing that
actually it didn't hurt my feelings but
it was he said like oh you're so
mentally broken they have to take
something like that comedians shouldn't
have to take what are you talking it's
it's I forget who weren't where I saw
but someone said like the brain is part
of the body that you take medicine for
heart you take medicine for breathing if
you have anxiety taking uphill doesn't
mean anything his whole point was that
oh you're we could you leave okay seven
years on the podcast I may take how many
time you see me drink let's count it we
drank with Ron white on the podcast
how many times you three seven years so
I could see if I was eating xanax and
abusing them I could see if I was
[ __ ] going out and trying to beer
listen or not telling anybody about it I
guess I'd do to [ __ ] him I've been
talking about a day on this show for
years I've been talking about my
personal issues with anxiety before I go
onstage when I leave my family go on the
road this is all I talk about because
I'm not better than you guys we all
[ __ ] bleed God put us together a
[ __ ] certain way and we'll all lack
in something or lack in something this
doesn't mean you're weak or whatever
this means that somewhere along the line
there was a [ __ ] problem that I
didn't correct but if you think I'm up
all night [ __ ] Noddin and [ __ ]
yeah I don't think sort of disturbing
but to myself there's no reason why I
should dog it's the truth I was telling
somebody like that drank one of those
quick Z bottles at night and I really
forgot how many edibles I took I didn't
know if I had taken two of those or four
I
I don't know so yeah am i embarrassed
for being 57 and waking up on the floor
with the heater burning me and the cat
meowing on me a little bit but you know
what from time to time you need to have
a little fun from time to time to remind
you of our buddy
grappling in science he doesn't love
memes he had one we'd there's no side
effects and sometimes you do wake up
with him and your and your sleep apnea
man yeah you know I said I woke up and
just ate a [ __ ] ham and just went
right to bed without brushing my teeth I
was like a [ __ ] Frankenstein but at
least I'm big enough to admit these
shortcomings if you're gonna make a tape
about me make it about the real thing
let's talk about the problems I had
grown out and do some research go get
some kidnap victims by the way I spoke
to my kidnap victim the other night he's
already smart aunts my dog down and
[ __ ] in Tucson I love camp with all
my heart you know I never understood why
people make these dumb videos and if
you're gonna call somebody out call them
out for the right reasons and then I
read some of the comments all he should
get arrested for Harvey whiner
guys listen you see how many women come
on my show do I look like a Harvey
Weinstein to you when I tell you that if
I get ten calls a day I'm iPhone six of
them a woman then I'm tight with then
I'm tight with when you're on the road
what happens on the road stays on the
road what happens in quarantine stays in
quarantine
you know do me a favor you gonna make a
video make it intelligent don't say I'm
fat
don't say I'm eighty don't say get to
the point prove that I lied because I've
been talking about anxiety for [ __ ]
years and you want me to say what
happened and I swear to my mother's
grave I didn't want to go out that day
right now I don't know if you guys are
paying attention if anybody has read
this 60 was selling 60% more alcohol
than before I'm sure yeah I got a weed
store that makes 15,000 on the weekends
they did fifty last weekend okay right
now I could be doing coke I could be
doing oxycottons I could be doing heroin
I'm doing [ __ ] a hundred milligrams
here a hundred milligrams there and a
xanax
if that bothers you that causes a
[ __ ] problem oh oh you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what the cause is
it really does that this is this is the
lightness of my life this is what keeps
me together in the daytime I can't I
can't [ __ ] breathe so this is a
problem in your life at this if you took
time to make a video about this I'm not
like I said I'm not gonna mention your
name so I watched the video cuz it
doesn't make sense I don't care if you
may even make up a thousand video make a
video about me [ __ ] kidnapping people
want you show video with a guy banged up
with a pitbull on little me and my
friend with a machine gun on them you'd
get more mileage with that me being a
[ __ ] junkie everybody already knows
you stupid [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ] ignorant
[ __ ] take your girlfriend teach you how
to suck your dick
take that [ __ ] whiskey you're throwing
away and take that stupid look off your
face you're not doing anybody you're
just going after people that are trying
to make a difference in any little way
they can and not for monetary reasons
but to just make it a little lighter
right now I should be eaten 20 of these
a day with what we're going through
right now woman the scariest [ __ ]
time of our lives I'm still coming down
here with my friend here and doing
entertainment and cracking a [ __ ]
couple jokes just to get you a little
Lucy can go back to your [ __ ] life
later on and feel a little better and
now you got to get these jerk-offs naked
videos right and [ __ ] articles about
louis c.k listen you want to find
something to do it your time help
yourself
don't write articles about other people
write articles and make videos about
this [ __ ] that you are the truly
[ __ ] he'll that you are as a human being
that's who you should be write the
[ __ ] video about how you have nothing
to do but you want out the Cheetos
auntie no
and crystally it is a no content that's
how much you can content do you have
that you want after two guys and have
nothing but [ __ ] content I can see if
you would have to me for no content but
those two guys so listen smarten up do
the best thing you could do for yourself
shoot yourself shoot the girl hang
yourself or become a man become a human
being and talk from the heart you
miserable [ __ ] and with that
that's it
[ __ ] these people it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's why I [ __ ] up the words and so
what if you were embarrassed about
taking anything tell someone this is
human [ __ ] life this is 57 hard
[ __ ] years of digging that just
wasn't made [ __ ] Twilight through the
tulips
this is a hard 57 and whose fault was it
it was mine it was nobody else's fault I
put myself in the position I was in but
for you to make a [ __ ] video for you
to write in our talk abouts Lucy Lucy
Ches line home right now counting 20
taking pictures of his nuts and sending
it to the guy to New York Times him and
a little [ __ ] Ronan Farrow whatever his
[ __ ] name is
Oh Woody Allen can't write a book here
we're all gonna walk out I don't agree
with woody and I don't like that
[ __ ] even but listen we're gonna
walk out and leave what do you think
there's a Jew down the corner he'll stab
you his mother for a million dollars
that's what Woody Allen want with his
book and the book of selling just flying
and everybody likes it I'm not gonna
read it I'm not gonna [ __ ] him by it I
know what he did he [ __ ] [ __ ] his
own little woman [ __ ] but God give him
what is coming to him having [ __ ]
Yoko Junior but it's got nothing to do
with me way I'm saying I don't want to
be in his movies I want to do not and do
you think that's going back to what you
started with like the change that's
gonna come from this I do you think
people are gonna like to start focusing
on themselves and being like well I read
that [ __ ] thing
not after I saw the thing about me and
that I saw the thing about louis c.k
look at the thing about me I knew was
coming any day I don't really give a
[ __ ] I got one foot in the grave one a
banana peel people know me know where my
heart is and that's all that matters
people who know me know that people make
mistakes 20 years ago and they're not
the same person anymore yeah you know
what louis c.k i hope you feel the same
I hope you look at louis c.k and see how
he's behaved since this has happened has
anybody else raised their hands and said
he's jerked off around the street maybe
you went for therapy maybe then but
don't shun him because of something that
happened in 2001 in a [ __ ] business
that is just disgusting it's just
disgusting
any day now Harvey's gonna get out of
jail you know why cuz somebody's gonna
give him a big check to tell him about
the chicks that did sleep with him and
what are you gonna do a Meryl Streep
named thumbs up on there and all these
[ __ ] famous Hollywood movie
stars what are you gonna do how are you
gonna feel about these women that won an
Academy Award
like the houston astros wanna [ __ ] a
World Series you know how are you gonna
feel about them that's the last poll
Harvey's gonna do isn't yeah it's go up
in an hour I'm gonna write a book about
all the [ __ ] that did suck my dick
don't want Academy Awards watch how many
[ __ ] are being fun that [ __ ] jail
which sticks free Harvey free Harvey
free Harvey we're never satisfied as
human beings you know for the last year
what have you heard about now I every
day the homeless problem the homeless
problem the homeless problem Gavin
Newsom the governor got him hotels did
you see that yeah you see what's going
on now yeah the people in the
neighborhood from the hotels [ __ ] the
whole same white people same [ __ ]
white people that were out there do
something for the [ __ ] - homeless same
white people now got signs we don't want
them in our neighborhood they got Kovach
19 go [ __ ] yourself you were the ones
that were all being Johnny Christian
nothing bothers me more than people who
go to church to think they're better
than you cuz they go to church when I
walk in the church you know what I see a
bunch of [ __ ]
creeps I see people trying to be [ __ ]
good
give me the guy that walks around every
day like Steve Simone that brings people
food that really helps old people that
really does that that's a real [ __ ]
Catholic Christian it doesn't mean that
you have to go to [ __ ] church and sit
the front [ __ ] peel my that's a most
people feel it takes for them to feel
better so [ __ ] me I'm a sinner
[ __ ] I'm gonna keep eating these
[ __ ] xanax I'm gonna go with her
[ __ ] weed store after this with my
little mask on and I'm gonna get some
supplies for the next couple days go get
smoked weed but that's it they're saying
if you smoke weed you're gonna die so
[ __ ] it we're gonna have to go back old
school to be any edibles at the house I
do all right tonight's your lucky night
guys second Hey
I love you guys with all my heart man
just
I appreciate the people who had my back
when they posted on our Facebook and
Twitter a lot of people attacked the guy
and told me is a sham now you could just
go after him full steam ahead tell him
his mother [ __ ] wears combat boots
his mother's ass all smells like xanax
just let him have it who gives a [ __ ]
he's a miserable [ __ ] he's eating later
down now somewhere down the road he'll
be doing videos or what's a guy gave the
edibles to that moved to the mountains
Oh Oh imagine him and all what he'll be
doing videos a year from now who gives a
[ __ ] hey I got [ __ ] no dates but I
want to talk to you about two things
again like manscape said it's tess
killer [ __ ] cancer month so make sure
you test out the testes you know I'm
saying you like Joey what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
I'll tell you what I'm talking about
it's a public service announcement for
your [ __ ] balls
April is test esculent Cancer Awareness
Month
all right just search ball checker
whenever you download apps they have an
app today four tips to protecting your
bean bag okay every hour someone in this
country is diagnosed with testicular
cancer early detection is your best
friend when it comes to protecting your
[ __ ] nuggets
smart manscape and the testicular cancer
society want to remind you that's right
you you [ __ ]
you gotta check that [ __ ] nutsack at
least once a month you're sitting at
home playing video game hey everything's
gonna be great unemployment is gonna
send me a check no they're not no
they're not this is the time you check
for for any early sign of changes
download the ball check out today for
tips on protecting that [ __ ] nutsack
just search ball checker and wherever
you download apps while you're down
there
your mothers will make sure that
everything is tip-top my gonna be
eyebrows I looked at my eyebrows the
other day I was embarrassed when I saw
him I saw bushes I saw black and see we
forget to go out and crush it now is the
time to trim [ __ ] and it starts with
your [ __ ] nutsack you want to be
prepared when this [ __ ] coronavirus
is over listen right now if I was 35 I'd
be planning one thing this thing's
coming back in the fall the summer I got
a plan I'm gonna sling dick though I get
the hit so if I get the coronavirus it
don't matter the hip overrides it [ __ ]
it so right now you got to shave your
nutsack and you got to shave around your
dick so it smells nice and it's ready
for the humidity because woman nobody
wants to something [ __ ] dirty dick
and if you're a guy you ever suck a
guy's dick and it smells weird above the
it smells like a Greek sandwich you
don't want that either so what I'm
telling you is this get some manscape
get the 3.0 get the crop duster
get the leather bag get it all because
this shit'll make your dick tip top
Magoo you want to make that area look
even if you got a little gut hanging
over it tell you what you take away the
[ __ ] ham and all they see is that
dick coming to him you put a little
Reviver and your nutsack so it doesn't
look like a [ __ ] bald ahead I can
help they put those balls in their mouth
who's better than you nobody you
understand me you bringing joy you're
like a [ __ ] you're like a priest on
Easter so get your [ __ ] together
go to manscape calm right now and use
toad words
Joey to get 20% off and free shipping
and if you got a little more
point-o they got an attachment to turn
it into 3.0 listen you need that 3.0 why
7,000 rpms chopping down all that
[ __ ] dirt and maluca hey you got
kazoo conditions the head wolf
nobody you put conditioning in that
Sarah no nobody has ever even thought
about that
you got a condition the nutsack so when
you shave down there the hair flies away
a lot easy you know I have a bunch of
dry ends
you look like [ __ ] one of those
Chinese girls I played well there for
fifteen hours and the wool and
interrogations nobody needs that go to
manscape calm right now
enter code Church I tell you what I'm
gonna give you 20% off your first order
and free shipping it's tough out there
but you gotta take care your dick that's
it and that's that do you want dates I
got no dates all I got fee is that the
church is now on Spotify and Liezel and
put a couple CDs on there for you for
free the other ways your time no more
they're free there for you okay I love
your mother [ __ ] wall yard I'm happy
you let me come across your living rooms
and I'm happy you understand where I'm
coming from
nah xanax I'll be beautiful whatever the
[ __ ] that is all right that's why I
didn't know the name of it [ __ ] smart
stupid [ __ ] anyway I love you
guys with all my heart please stay in
please stay safe we do the podcast we
keep the door open I come in here every
day I'll i saw ozium [ __ ] fart in
here i got everything covered if you
could take one of my farts you could
take the corona virus there's no big
[ __ ] deal alright I love your
[ __ ] I got no dates on the book
so I'm not interested
I'm interested right now and you get
healthy you get in your pocket straight
and then after that we'll talk about
dates and jumping up and down and
selling t-shirts or whatever for right
now entertain yourself and manscape it
listen you smoke a joint you start
trimming your balls you'll never stop by
the end of the night I'll have you in a
yoga position you'll never see you'll
have your hand up your [ __ ] shaving
with a mirror by your ear stuck with a
paperclip have some fun
manscape calm my bookie died AG / Joey
thank you very much take this [ __ ]
meal Lee
[Music]